une personne victime on cherche de la
haine et déjà d'appeler parfois c'est
déjà en soi quelque chose donc on va
avoir une équipe d'avocats qui
disponibles la conférence de presse
annonçant la création du rabat si on
n'était pas terminée que déjà de
téléphone sonner depuis un petit peu
plus d'un mois et les victimes de
violences conjugales ou sexuelles au
québec peuvent obtenir quatre heures de
consultations juridiques au téléphone ou
par visioconférence
c'est gratuit et s'est offert à tout le
monde oui bonjour
aujourd'hui la très grande majorité de
la clientèle qui appelle et féminine est
victime de violences conjugales
les avocats les guident à travers
plusieurs domaines du droit moi par
exemple je fais du droit de la famille
mais si une personne n'appelle me
raconte son histoire jean tinguely qu'
il ya eu des menaces de mort il ya une
harcèlement criminel je vais demander à
la personne la met en attente j'ai
vérifié la disponibilité au legs en
criminels qui appelle tout le monde il
n'y a pas d'âge il n'y a pas de couleur
il n'y a pas de langue n'ya pas de
religion et on reçoit des appels de gens
qui nous disent on mais moi c'est pas
vraiment de la violence et de la petite
violence parce que j'ai pas de marque
j'ai pas de trace on est là pour les ex
gloires expliqué que la violence à la
plateforme ça se présente sous plusieurs
formes on s'en tient des mégane et si
après les quatre heures de consultations
gratuites la victime a encore besoin
d'être guidés par un avocat et serait
dirigée vers l'aide juridique ou un
avocat en pratique privée passe quelque
chose qui vous a surpris oui je trouve
que moi personnellement les appels que
j'ai eues on a beaucoup de violence post
séparation la violence du type un peu
harcèlement menaces mais avec les outils
technologiques mais les gens on et
textos lyon les messenger et on les
facebook qui ont des moyens pour garder
un certain contrôle en fait alors on est
aussi là pour justement essayer de voir
au niveau légal au niveau du système de
justice qu est-ce qui peut mise en place
pour faire cesser cette violence post
séparation
constatation n'est pas anodine elle est
aussi à l'image de certains féministes
qui se sont produits cette année au
québec où les victimes avaient déjà
quitté leur conjoint on reçoit des
appels de gens peut-être qu'ils ne le
verbalise pas tous mais certaines
victimes le verbalisent week elle crée
avec le prochain film ici donc ça le
solde positif la halle le fait d'en
parler comme on en parle maintenant mon
ami lisette fut victime du 12e prix mini
site de l'année au québec vous
comprendrez ma motivation diriger ce
service marie claude richez et celle qui
dirige rebâtir qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ce premier mois en opération
on réalise comment les gens ne savent
pas des fois par quel bout commencer
on se rend compte c'est qu'on fait et je
suis certaine maintenant une différence
dans la vie de ces gens là j'irai même
jusqu'à dire que dans certaines
situations ne même peut-être sauver des
vies dans le milieu des organismes qui
viennent en aide aux personnes victimes
de violences conjugales on estime que la
création de cet outil juridique était
nécessaire toutes les femmes qui sont
toute seule chez elle et qu'ils
cherchent comment s'en sortir avaient
pas accès à cette information là et
souvent ne savait pas où la trouver
c'est sûr que des sites comme éducaloi
mais soucier de l'information générale
alors que là on peut avoir une
information précise
louise riendeau voudrait même que ce
service de conseil juridique soit
élargie pour être faire directement dans
les maisons d'hébergement
[Musique]